gang christmas came early this year
cause the are you garbage special is on
youtube right now yeah guys go share
with your friends hit them up in the
group chat tell people who aren't
familiar with the show this is a perfect
way to introduce them check it out it's
a good time a lot of laughs thanks for
watching love you welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they're good to be classy
yeah or you're just a big old piece of
[ __ ] i'm your host nate's foley coming
at you on a beautiful day down here in
antoni's basement she wanted to remind
everybody she still has vax cards and
boosters available for sale on her
website
tony.org my co-host is coming at you
from across the table it's a family
episode just the boys in here the boys
the bozos and the homies
he is uh the ceo of are you garbage thus
far he has led us to the promised land
everybody's like napoleon everybody
i'm gonna ruin you on an island when i'm
done with you ladies and gentlemen give
it up for kj did not like that comment i
could tell no no no i didn't open over
no issue with it what's up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube but as you
know those numbers are true to roof uh
and then obviously patreon.com shout out
to all the [ __ ] homies on there you
can sign up you get bonus episodes ayg
hard feelings the [ __ ] live streams
the whole nine yards but you know that
yeah check it out over there that's
[ __ ] cooking
what about the the one uh
what's up well when you go out to dinner
do you order the special that's what i
was gonna say
let me hear the spanish
run in back what's for the appetizer i
ain't talking about the marsala either i
can tell you that you can save the soup
because we got a specie that's right
gang got the special on the youtube page
up streaming get on there if you're not
subscribed to the youtube page subscribe
subscribe subscribe share that puppy as
much as you can someone get it
appreciate everybody someone said
someone get it on reddit i want that
front page of reddit or something yeah
why are you guys redditers out there
hackers doing yeah get in the back there
you go hack into the
find some bitcoin i don't know what you
gotta do something like coin i'm a
litecoin man everybody knows that and
speaking of the special all right the
mastermind of the are you garbage
special give it up for t-bone
mcscruffins tomy toby
mcbuggins
what up dude what up
dude nothing that thing's out now i'm a
sunglasses inside guy yeah i'm gonna get
a convertible i can't legally drive this
is like your opus this special a lot a
lot of years a lot of thought i've been
wanting to make something like this for
a long time no this is the indie that
toby does that gets a lot of attention
then
before he really lays a stinker on us
yeah the hollywood big budget thank you
you're gonna you're gonna get
transformer six and [ __ ] lunch it i
will say i learned a lot in that edit i
can't wait to get back out on the road
running back yeah there you go there you
go we love it um
family episode we're here today
you signed up for the old patreon you uh
you get your questions right on the air
sure do i had a piece of business i
wanted it i got a little bit of
something i want to get into too this is
light i wanted to run this body light a
buddy of mine
buddy of ours friend of ours i don't
want to say who it is i don't know what
his uh relationship status is now oh boy
but was telling me
um a week or two ago sure something
about exes something about exes came up
like do you talk to your exes i live in
texas anything like that yes i deserve
better
no it didn't
okay i see how we're starting
he was saying
that they have to keep somewhat of a
decent relationship a friendly
relationship okay because they share a
phone plan oh
now is there i know you don't have this
maybe you do or did or whatever
you ever get higher don't
i didn't mean stop it those automatic
payments stopped
yeah that's insane to me it's like uh
you know what you're too poor to break
up i don't understand it well it's i
just how much money you save what's
happening i understand the
comfortability of it like you get into
those things you don't feel like
changing that [ __ ] oh dude i was with
cause i had a [ __ ] panic i've been
dude i've been with this company so long
when i started out it was voice stream
really i was voice stream that i think
somebody got a hold of them t-mobes
maybe and then i was a sprint man for op
dude sprint's a tough look dude they're
passing me around like a loose joint
sprint's a bad soda
well t-mobile just bought sprint
i don't know i got booted i was with a
family i was with a company plan when i
was working for the when i was working
for the outfit when i was working for
the family
then things went a little south and i
got booted toot sweet off that's to
change your number the hangover wasn't
even off yet and i was off that [ __ ]
plan the ad builder hadn't even kicked
in and i was off the plan lippy at the
office
that holiday party ended you have to
change your number had to change my
number which was i had to change my
number now i'm going all the way i'm
going new identity yeah it was moving to
seattle bleaching my hair it was a nice
good take up surfing
it was a nice fresh start of like i'm
i need i was walking away from a lot of
skeletons wow yeah you only change your
number when you get out of rehab that's
the only reason you change your number
you get out you keep it
you don't visit the old haunts
i say that however the reason i'm
sympathetic to it
is because uh you're on your pain you're
on you're on your parents plan i'm not
on my we share a family plan yeah i mean
that's who uh what whose name is it it's
not in your name
yeah
i'm i'm a registered user though yeah
yeah
i could you had to be to get nights and
weekends
he's got to walk around the neighborhood
and tell everyone that he just moved him
hey guys i'm hey guys i'm i'm on a
family plan just want to let you know i
gotta go legally i have to go
door-to-door tell you guys that i'm a
[ __ ] loser let you know i'm a bozo
so if you have any old cell phones or
anything
anything in a junk drawer
dude you go to my mom's house it's like
a graveyard for flip phones that's crazy
it's like a radio shack in that place
like she's moving h what the [ __ ] all
burners you what dude there's like first
of all my mom's house is turning into
like one big drunk it's just like it's
silverware and then the rest are junk
drawers and tupperware they're they're
multiplying it's all just old rubber
bands and stuff
thread that'll never get used
i say that with sympathetic ears because
i'm involved in a family plan what are
some associates when are you gonna get
out of that uh i think i'm doing it uh
[ __ ] never you [ __ ] [ __ ] what are
you nuts it's [ __ ] comforting in
there that's right my family what do you
mean it's a supporter you just haven't
you know your mommy's taking care of you
that's how you like it
yeah
she handles the paper [ __ ] up i assume
it's something he handles the paperwork
i.e she pays the bill at the end of the
month i assume it's not on your credit
card i know that much
it's not getting taken out of yours
capital one wouldn't have it yeah um
i i assume at some point or my plan is
at some point that patty will come
we'll eventually be working for the
organization
not not ours me my my own entity she'll
be one of my people
she handles [ __ ] man she gets stains out
like dickens
[Laughter]
chief anxiety officer
oh i'm on the board of crazy actually
no i see her i see her taking over like
a kris jenner role at some point let me
get you in a sex tape
you want a black guy why did you give me
beers
wine for breakfast all right you an r b
singer oh that's [ __ ] beautiful no i
eventually you know like to bring her
into the fold
doing well
what down the road i don't know handling
some things well yeah i i don't know
[ __ ] flights hotels like he's like a
personal assistant she's good with all
that [ __ ] you know how rappers will like
buy their mom a house yeah foley's
version of that is gonna be an ig story
of like thanks for all the love you know
i just got off my mom's family plan yeah
she's working i'm gonna get her i'm
gonna get her a trailer office at some
construction
get her a gang box
got my mom in a wee work like a piece of
[ __ ] yeah
you don't you don't let her and your dad
unionize
sending a union buster
she's asking for paid overtime
ah man
you would be horrible to work for what
do you mean
i don't know how else to say it
i was pretty blunt with that what do you
mean t-bone how am i
if you think i work for you you're nuts
i've never got the youtube's password
i'm not even sure you know where you are
right now
oh man that's why i need my mom [ __ ]
middleman
who's gonna pay the bills
i tell you if she if she knew anything
about technology she'd be all right
that's the only problem we'd both be
funneling around with the phones in the
dark yeah both getting locked out of
accounts and stuff
is it my birthday or your birthday oh
jesus
i had i went through that this weekend
because my phone was [ __ ] getting
cute on me i thought i was about to pull
the trigger i was gonna get though you
can't get these iphone 13s anymore these
kids are all over them okay can't get
them
but they do have the maxes remember
remember the the pluses for a little
while they were the bigger versions of
the phones yeah i guess they have a
version of that for the for the 13.
anybody who had those that was always a
bozo movement
you're walking around with a [ __ ]
tablet in your hand yeah how do you dial
that thing to one two
who did that that was the body of mine
did that
i mean you remember those you remember
when you're a pretty good bit
yeah when you get got i showed up to
like a hanging car like high school or
something i had a big
it was like i had a big phone it was
like when big phones like just came out
if it's not an iphone you're it was it
was big android had a kickstand on it do
you remember that thing
they gave you that for free that came
with the plan yeah it was a pull start
too
[Laughter]
kind of gas that thing takes a
two-stroke
oh my phone's out the mix is all [ __ ]
up and making a generator my juice is
dead
i use regular gaze
give me
give me shovel and coal into the back of
the phone i'm on a stationary bike like
the polar express hold on i gotta text
my girl
oh [ __ ] yeah that thing's stung i told
you i got him up a couple of times that
android they got me with the kickstand
well you could put it up and you could
watch it like you know what i mean i'm
not bragging i'm like you know i'm
letting you know the functionality of
the product
video it loads my next tuesday
it was good it was good it was quite it
was the when android came out was faster
than the iphone at the time like the
whatever
they had some sort of something i don't
give a [ __ ] that's what it does
never went back never never went back
crazy um
that and then i did i've said
a couple of times i fell for the zune
instead of the ipod
back in the day what's a zoo exactly
zune was mine sounds like a rare bird
the yellow spotted zoom
yeah this [ __ ] this [ __ ] jerk off
at best buy on delaware ave saw me
coming really real slick tucker huh oh
yeah
get you and you're coming in where you
going buddy i had a blue zoom or
something
it was bad
crazy but my phone was [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the bed and i started to transfer
my we we had an old one laying around so
i'm like i gotta i want to get this [ __ ]
off there backed everything up in the
cloud and when you download these
[ __ ] apps again from the cloud you
got it you got to use your password i
don't [ __ ] know what my password was
for instagram [ __ ] 10 years ago or
eight years ago uh-huh [ __ ] jamming
me up yeah
it's tough that's how they get you try
to get you there's too many passwords
man it's tough to keep [ __ ] track and
if you don't sign in i'm now i have my
computer use the same one that's that's
not a [ __ ] hacker i know but they're
always like oh this one needs a special
character so you put the [ __ ] you
know
you put the exclamation point somewhere
else and you forget where you put it i
put a beginning the end
uppercase lowercase that's [ __ ]
implant whatever you want in here so i'm
not going to remember any passwords man
well they uh my computer has the finger
john like it just re like all of my
things are so is my girlfriend
uh
it has a
beat do it fatty
said anything bad about my wife
turn it on my girlfriend should have
shot i should have shot under the table
i tried to be a gentleman and raise the
guard no
his gun got caught in the holster
not this time bart
uh okay
holy saying
you're about to tell us your passwords
[Laughter]
big head004
um no i have my uh it saves it on my
computer and i just use my fingerprint
and that has all my passwords saved sure
but if you try to log in on something
else
i'm used to it's better when you have to
manually enter them because you remember
them now i'm [ __ ] wall i don't know
anything this thing was asking me for
like triple verification they wanted me
to remember the password of my
girlfriend's old laptop that i guess i
hooked my phone up to at one point
what are you [ __ ] fact checking me
over here it's me
hit me up come on
chuckle hank
what are we doing here
[Laughter]
yeah the biebs got to deal with this
[ __ ]
he's got a guy he's mine it's not his
mom either that's good
doesn't his mom work for him
i don't think she scooter yeah
did we talk about that on patreon no
yeah we talked about a patreon for the
listener me and foley did a show
i believe
me and foley did a show in front of
scooter braun who's like the head of
music he's like ceo of music of
entertainment
and fully bombed
so bad in front of him it was a tough
scene and just kept going oh man you did
about 38 minutes of material in a five
minute yeah didn't [ __ ] didn't adjust
at all just kept marching through like a
like a redcoat
step left and right you know what i mean
that was something else it's somebody
where they're from or something yeah
do something bring me up i don't know
we'll do something together give me just
stand there i was standing in the back
like holy [ __ ] smoking like a frenchman
i'm going to sit for him
i'm going to i'm going to be hearing
about this for the next three weeks
smoking back there like jean gerard i
got something that's real trashy too
before we get into the patreon qualions
what's that is it your john goodman
shirt what are you talking about
i'm waiting for roseanne to walk in
[Laughter]
you do have a neighbor whose job is to
move the narrative vibes oh yeah we're
gonna put up a picture of what you're
wearing right now t-bone he's in a
situation yeah i'm not allowed to say
because i'm a nice guy yeah
check out the patreon
yeah you want the inside scoop on his
bozo check out the patreon on a picture
i'll find out why toby's wearing pajamas
right now
and dress shoes
got a one bedroom with about 1100
roommates oh god well that gave it away
a couple of freeloaders too
they're not paying around if you catch
my drift talk about a family plan
yikes
he's got the queen working for
that always freaked me out in science
toby's really bugging me but
anybody want to go to bed
it always freaked me out when i was a
kid and they would show the queen
and she'd be like a normal nice lady she
should she'd be a normal bug and then
she'd just have a huge like [ __ ] clip
like a rap
oh
a family program
uh she would have like a wrap sandwich
behind her remember it was as like her
egg sack or whatever it was whatever
they called it sandwich
you know what i'm talking about like
that big thing that was always attached
to the queen where she pooped out the
other bug
i don't think you know how anything
works where she pooped out
she had her big egg sack where she
pooped out the other bug yeah she would
like she would be huge she would look
like a normal bug but then she would
just have like a huge ass
what did you guys go to public school
what's going on
a couple of jesus freaks over here
i love when we just let you go sometimes
and you get mad nervous
it's me it's them right
you guys understand
this is ridiculous you're crazy you know
what i'm talking about sure yeah i don't
know why you're still disappointed yeah
i know what you're talking about i don't
know what do you want from me
a little bit yeah you do it's striking
this is a silly one boys and girls dude
that was like watching a guy hang
themself and then grab more rope and
start tying another noose
8 000 pound test on this guy
[ __ ] is wrong with you what happened um
as you know
um i recently upgraded to a king-sized
bed in my apartment yes
put it together got the new bed frame
still using a queen-size bed for him
it's like an over stop sandwich like
laying on a whopper
jesus christ
sleeping in a triple whopper holy [ __ ]
man come on
oh
this one is cookie
big piece of lettuce for sheets i've
been trying to get freaky on that thing
gonna be rolling off the side
oh god all right so
i'm crying holy [ __ ]
i recently got a king size bed
so
i had a relatively new
[ __ ] helix mattress yes that's the
king oh you haven't had they they sent
us one when they started advertising
right maybe about what let's call it oh
eight months ago something like that six
eight months so something like that
they got it last spring so not too long
ago
so now i just upgraded got the king size
because i toss and turn i got the king
size
so now i got this mattress and i got the
bed frame and i'm like a big she did the
fries at the onion rings
[Music]
are you kidding me i thought that was
gonna break the internet i know jesus
because the kid the whopper thing yeah i
mean that was yeah sure kip let's talk
about black buffalo did you say black
buffalo i said black buffalo tell you
right now if you're over 21 uh-huh and
you're into the snuff and the dip and
the this the chew the pouches the long
cuts whatever get out of that [ __ ] gotta
get out there's alternatives now uh-huh
black buffalo is absolutely fantastic
yeah guys uh black belt hose everything
you love about dipping including the
pharmaceutical grade nicotine just
without the actual tobacco leaf for
stems uh the dip is literally made from
edible green leaves food grade
ingredients nice same flavors textures
aroma pack and nicotine as traditional
tobacco products no compromises required
there you go uh they also have a
subscription option uh on their core
flavors so you can set it and forget it
comes to the door boom bam boom really
whenever you need your fix they got you
you don't gotta go down to the thing and
then look at that i don't have my cash
on somebody getting lottery tickets you
know then then you're getting a [ __ ]
candy bar and it is like that thing
beautiful best thing about it
made in the u.s of a yeah
look at this born in the midwest raised
in the south these are some good old
boys baby what i'm talking about what it
says yeah no i mean i made that up but
black i'm ripping over here black
buffalo proudly manufactures their
products in the us of a there you go um
don't take our word for it they were
2021's best new product winner at the
csp awards and cs store decisions hot
new products award winner 2012 21. look
at that i mean come on what are we doing
here sounds like clean living to me yeah
um guys it's a new year it's about to be
a new year and you are one of the 10
million people if you are one of the 10
million people who are 21 and over dip
tobacco consider turning over a new leaf
see what we did there and switching like
it switching to black buffalo it's
everything you love about dipping just
without the actual tobacco stem or leaf
head to blackbuffalo.com use promo code
garbage at checkout for 25 off your
first order 25 best offer you'll find
anywhere use our code garbage for 25 of
your first order one last time promo
code garbage 25 off your first order i
got to read this warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical kimby how about our
good friends over there dad grasp bad
grass a little story all right you know
i like to dabble every once in a while
huh did i get all goofy yeah bad grass
is perfect it's the perfect amount of
mellow perfect amount of chill yeah no
paranoia no nothing like that listen i
ain't no spring chicken anymore you know
what i mean i like to relax just like
the next guy take the edge off that
grass is legal organo organic smokable
hemp that relaxes your body and mellows
your mind it's nice 100 organic
pre-rolled joints are very low in thc
but high in cbd so you can enjoy the
effects of cbd while keeping your head
clear
uh dag grasses also has cbd tinctures
made from the same high quality hemp
easy to dose and the effects come on
smooth chill without getting stoned it's
like having a glass of wine not the
whole bottle it's nice all dag grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and ships right to your door
anywhere in the u.s of a right now dog
grass is offering our listeners what
twenty percent off your first order when
you go to dagrass.com garbage go to
dadgrass.com garbage 20 percent off your
first order one more time write it down
dadgrass.com garbage links in the
description do it
digress
holy [ __ ]
my ghost is a wart everybody jesus
christ you look like you just got
dude i don't even
that's too much for me to process at the
moment to be honest with you
what in the [ __ ] is going on
toby don't he was saying bad things
about you when you went to the bathroom
my real name is delmar holy [ __ ] well
i'm wearing a [ __ ] hat
letting my hair grow
it looked like you did it with shoe
polish to be honest with you
a little bit of mink oil in there you
ever get into trouble with shoe polish
when you were a kid i opened my dad my
dog
[ __ ] my dad had a green tackle box in
the bottom of the closet that i opened
up oh man i look like a coal miner after
that i got yeah i got that [ __ ]
everywhere you got another candy dish
dude
that stuff doesn't come off [ __ ] in
black for a week
[Laughter]
all right oh but so now with my you know
uh my wife's like it's a shame
to just throw away this mattress you
know she's a nice lady and she's like
there's you know there's people in need
we're in a position of fort like we're
we're fortunate let's you know try to
give it to tough times people out of
work christmas the whole thing so let's
see if anybody needs it you know what i
mean like someone that's like in a bad
situation might need a new bed or you
know something for their kids or
something
so she puts it up on online now she's
got this like she's doing it with like
everything in the apartment
like she's getting rid of like clothes
and stuff and there's like obviously a
lot of people in a lot of people out of
work just we just made a cute i told you
i cleaned out my closet we just did a
huge bag for goodwill
buy old winter coats in there
that's like that's like a three-bedroom
house for somebody oh man that jacket
huge that thing stunk to high heavens
that was the worst jacket i've ever seen
it didn't smell like a peach either oh
that was the year we were trucking
around i showered maybe once or twice a
week had that real winter funk on me
start to like it after a while it's
weird man you're another kind of weird
dude you really truly are
continue now we got all these she's
giving away the form we got all these
people coming like she's getting rid of
clothes and dresses and jackets and
everything because she's like on this
like gift giving hot or like you know
like uh how i'm helping out the
community she is
but it's like i'm like lady just [ __ ]
take it all to one place and dump it you
know what i mean also it's like the bed
frame was like 80 bucks to begin with
from the river's right there oh what are
we doing
a bridge i'll burn it there
it's like it's like a revolving door
people no i'm here to pick up the
flip-flops i'm here to pick up though i
hate hip-hop yeah it's crazy big ticket
items huh well then one guy
i had a i had a school bag uh jan sport
you give me a
i had a school bag that she posted and
it was like ripped where's she posting
this there's like a facebook group
nah there's like uh in need facebook
pinterest
no i keep naming things i'm not quite
sure you know what they are i'm not
positive yeah uber
um
so some dude just showed up at your
house people do that to case places
the case the joints see who's coming in
or did you meet him
the drop point
no then the hole he's not coming in the
apartment
okay
uh
but we gave him a school bag so he's
like oh here's a school bag it's like
this thing was right so you put on this
on this phone i'm not doing anything
let's be sure you put on this form hey
if anybody just cool back come and get
it somebody actually came together the
guy needed a school bag i needed a
school bag here i found out
he's like oh he told my wife uh jansport
has an unlimited
if you send back a damaged product
they'll send you a new product so does
timberland or l.l bean or somebody does
that yeah or used to know it i think if
you create enough stink don't
sure yeah you know any customer service
but just [ __ ] here yeah it's costing
us eight bucks to get you off the phone
bozo kick [ __ ] rocks so his whole
plan was to take it to try to get a new
school bag
wow or get it fixed wouldn't they repair
it nah they'll just send you a new one
i'm gonna repair it i don't know it
seems like a lot it's not a transmission
just send you a new one we're waiting on
parts
hey napa know-how what are we doing look
at these left straps anywhere
pay through the nose
well that's nice man good for you mazel
yeah i'm saying i feel like it's trashy
i feel like we're i feel like we're
doing a [ __ ] garage sale in my
apartment not not if you're giving it
away was there any money exchanged
no
she wants to get some for the
mattress though because it is she wants
to get some some cash you put it up for
like hey you know 200 or something what
yeah that's
that you didn't pay for that
that was given as a promotional gift you
wanted that on a game show i had to pay
for it with my endorsements
okay with your hard work so you get you
get 40 of it yes t-bone with his beak
all right do you want the price of that
mattress went up a little bit now okay
give someone else your [ __ ] fart box
oh i'm sorry oh yeah
you're gonna be sleeping in the
refrigerator
this guy yeah is my is my mattress not
good enough for your bed bugs
[ __ ] sleeping goggles on because of
the smoke bombs going off in there um
yeah but let's get into it we got some
[ __ ] questions this is a [ __ ] barn
burner wacky one baby um
guys so as you know when you join a
patreon we will answer your garbage
questions i told them
oh did you yeah okay
let him know what's up um this is from
dr nut funk
i think he's an associate of mr h
foley's
edgar you have something to say
you just seem a little salty about those
fries still what fries
i don't know i didn't get either one of
the jokes
to be honest with you i didn't get his
and i definitely get your origin i
didn't get the source material to begin
with oh that was edgar from um
uh men in black yeah okay in the
suit get me water yeah
that's gonna be toby the guy shout out
to the bug man
he was wearing like an egg suit
a bunch of bed bugs are gonna come in
here wearing a toby suit
typing real fast they got multiple likes
um
i just post
for you kids in the back of the class
all right this one's from dr nut funk
love it uh any family members refer to
themselves as inventors
he goes one of my uncles invented a
computer keyboard attached to a recliner
to use
that's bad i think that's just a
wireless that's just a
that's just a keyboard and a recliner
that's all that is that's just the guy
without a job man that's all that is
this guy likes to whack it
[Music]
ah that's great
i might as a guy sitting down looking
around the room
just yeah
what can i put together here
[Laughter]
what if the tv tray was in the couch
that's actually a really [ __ ] good
idea
what's that like if you had you know on
airplanes you have the the tray that
pops up on the in the side horrible idea
but then it's in this one i'm gonna put
another couch in front of you
no you're sitting on the couch and then
on the on the arm rest it opens up built
into a couch is trash cup holders
anything [ __ ] uh anything they're
great they're fantastic but they're
trash they're this dude the bottom of
that cup holder stays clean for about 42
minutes and then after that
there's like dumb stick stiff dump
what are they
dumb dumb sticks
and these goldfish pennies that are
welded to the bottom of that thing you
can't get them jaws out
uh yeah they're disgusting disgusting
disgusting i might have a couple of
family members or might know some people
that have patents
really but not like you don't come from
patent people not like good patents like
little patents i was the first guy to
ever [ __ ] my dog
you owe me 20 bucks if you [ __ ] a beagle
[ __ ] hillbillies
you don't come from patented somebody
does
no you're making this up yeah my i'm
my sister-in-law's father was an was an
inventor i know the product yes can we
say it i believe so
the dildo ha ha the jack camera
uh the floaby the flowbee
yeah yeah he's connected to flowbee
money yeah i don't know how much i mean
i think they sold a couple of them in
the 80s well your crate guy's got to be
a billionaire that's not a true a
billionaire you're nuts
no
that's you're nuts those things went
like hot you want to remember this man
i've never
yeah
no no one has man there was like an
infomercial for a weekend only in a
museum a museum
a museum people had them though oh yeah
i'm sure a lot of people tried to make
their own after that yeah looking up
clippers with a vacuum cleaner ma'am try
it out on the dog first yeah
[ __ ] border collie with a jacked up
haircut
border collie with the mohawks all right
i'm thinking that right now
yeah but he was an inventor and he's
like he did something but then later in
his life he was that's an inventor yeah
he was like a proper like the flex seal
guys they're inventors
yeah you know i think that was just a
guy who like toughened ronco romp appeal
toronto peel's a proper inventor yeah
fine american as well
uh i did dude do you know anybody that
has a ron poo peel pasta maker
no he sold millions of them sure i'm
sure i do know somebody yes i'm sure one
of my aunts or somebody has round poo
peel so i'm sure somebody out there has
a flowbee in their basement or in their
attic or crawl space
crawl space yeah you don't have a crawl
space oh no we've gone over this we
definitely do yeah that's where the
[ __ ] heebie jeebies live daddy
longlegs oh man
clear it air
that's where bedbugs come it's toby's
apartment
um
yeah but what are you googling there
scratchy more than 200 000 flow bees
have been sold yeah that's not that 200
000 that's all they that was
i mean that that but that's from january
7 1993
i think that's when they came it came
out in the early 90s oh it had to be
before that
get worldwide sales
gross
you are
[Laughter]
worldwide sales of the flowbee
there's no way only 200 000 i don't know
if i've actually units were moved i
don't know if i've ever actually talked
to her about i could be wrong i mean
that's in the national zeitgeist that
was you know i think but like as a not a
joke but like as a novelty thing what
about the thigh master you think a lot
of people that's made money off those
suzanne summers whether be cooked we had
one we had one yeah [ __ ] i was i was
doing the iron man with that thing
put in your butt cheeks
of steel
keep the ash tight at the pool this year
what do you got there buddy
uh uh
so far
the first thing i saw in this article as
i'm flipping through is the reaction of
the county fair crowd may have been on
hunt's mind which is like amazing i
don't think this is him i might be
making this whole thing up this isn't
the guy let me see
that's a
that that's like a college kid that's
not her dad
i might have made this whole thing from
my space
he looks like tom but bran
dude by the year 2000 they sold two
million of these [ __ ] things there
you go
the more this the more this is that no
but i think i think this whole thing is
fabricated i never talked i got to talk
to her at christmas i got wet my beak on
this floaby bunny oh [ __ ]
okay please get my pubes dripping
i want to go to the mud room and clean
up real quick
yeah this isn't right
why is there a picture of that guy young
kid that's the guy who invented it rick
e hunts
no wait let me see the picture again
that's him
when i don't think so unless she's a
time traveler invented in 86. wow
there you go
shout out to him
good for him look at that you learned
something new 150 retail what is that
there you go that saves billions of
dollars
if he sold 2 million two million times
150 is billions of dollars
is it not it is one it's billions no a
billion it's three if you're if it's if
each one sold for 150
and there is you sold
a million it'll be 150 million yeah so
it was 2 million be 300 million still
pretty good yeah packaging alone
research and development r d but with
inflation that's like 9 10 billion
that's true is it really i think so yeah
oh you idiot
um
wow well i gotta get to the bottom of
that that's a home run of a question
that is a home run i can't believe we
can't believe we've never had that one
beautiful this one also a real humdinger
josh ever fall off a roof
[Laughter]
it says ever fall off a roof question
mark tough luck
[Laughter]
man i had a cousin who fell off a roof
it was yeah
they tell you was he okay i mean he was
hemmed up for a little bit but he
shouldn't have been poking his nose
where it didn't belong you know what i
mean was he peeping what oh no no no
they were drinking that's what i thought
that's one good thing i get that feeling
in my belly button and my peter when i
get when i'm on a roof so one good thing
about the bureau of crazy they really
instilled all that stuff into me don't
go near anything hot get off don't go
near a roof you're gonna fall you're
gonna get hurt you're gonna get this
you're gonna go out in the ocean you're
gonna get drowned uh keeps me nice and
safe kip let's talk about roman roman
good people
and i mean doing a lord's work over
there people over there roman they're
keeping this whole little little cycle
we call life moving and shaking yeah you
know what i like about him uh-huh people
over there roman yeah get to talk to
them yeah get to see what you need
mm-hmm and i'm just throwing [ __ ]
this and that at you no not at all
yeah with roman you get a free online
evaluation ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy you're your own home a u.s
licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find a best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate it
ships free to you with two-day shipping
if they're not just signing anybody can
just take a reservation today i like
that dude that right to the doctor bam
bam you gotta make three five business
days yeah you got a leak in the toilet
you need to eat it plugged up right now
for sure uh
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com garbage complete the online
visit take care of your ad without ever
leaving your house connect with a u.s
licensed health care professional and
take care of it go to
getroman.com today and if you're
prescribed you'll get 15 bucks 15 clams
15 15 greenbacks off your first no
percentage just straight cash straight
cash that's what i'm talking about uh
off your first month of ed treatment
make sure you're ready and have the
confidence and control of this season
roman ready yeah now back
to the show
if someone sends us a flowbee we will
cut my hair with it on the patreon okay
that's pretty good i know i know the
owner i get my hands on one pubes too
oh god all right um
this is from sweet james never had a
question red had you ever separated
two-ply toilet paper
now that [ __ ] always drove me crazy
that's crazy you know every once in a
while like on oprah becca's old oprah
good oprah when it was real it was a
little trashy in the 90s yeah she puts
on a good front of being like america
and she was doing like did you ever [ __ ]
your cousin's wife oh yeah she was
[ __ ] she was a mudslinger yeah dude
100
what do you mean great lady though she's
doing all right
she's a billionaire yeah proper
billionaire right yeah of course what do
you think she's got
i mean two billion dollars two billion
three billion t-bone what she got
oops what you rocking
2.6 god damn i was dead on
that's why you handle the books baby i
know you what do i have yeah i can i can
get there oh you want to know how much
money i have i know you're i'll say your
net worth
what does that mean i got bills and [ __ ]
yeah money you have versus money owed on
the street oh that's not good
you're in a red if you're throwing
francis you're in the red yeah yeah i'm
upside down in the bag yet
you're kidding me
you want to probably eat what okay let's
just say what i got what i got in the
kitty right now
what's in your
accounts yeah minus any
lines of credit
yeah yeah forget all that just cold hard
cash american greenbacks
t-bills what do i got um
i know what i have and i know what you
make well no [ __ ] you know what you have
i would say
is france paid for
now
the flight's paid for okay
the hotel they took 300.
i would say
you have sheets what pay to pay for the
rubber sheets
i would say you probably have six
thousand dollars
fifty six hundred
he played the atm machine with him
earlier
peeking over his shoulder ah
that's about right
plus i got a jihad in the capital one
card
keeping that thing in the garage until
it reaches
put the snow tires on that phone
no one touches that
that doesn't leave the apartment until
it turned on our way to the airport
okay that's good yeah
um
yeah that but she used to go back to
over she used to do that stuff how'd i
like save you know
reuse the [ __ ] whatever for the
wedding she dragged some family on there
from like the midwest we're like here's
the [ __ ] whoever's and their dad
doesn't let them buy this or doesn't buy
that do they haven't bought paper towels
in three years because they peel them
apart and all stuff i imagine living
like that i can't i mean necessity is
one thing but that's not what we're
talking about i'm not talking about a
family that has to do it they do it to
like beach frugal and save money yeah
you know but like you know
generally everybody's okay it's not like
they're doing it because they really
have to yeah of course i've been there
people just get into those zones like
the coupon clippers and uh
this and that i told you i i had one
girlfriend that her dad on the weekends
would go around to like different
hallmark stores and cvs stores and buy
things that were like on discount sale
yeah it didn't matter just whatever time
of the year
and he was [ __ ] rich
yeah i don't have time for that i
couldn't do one ply not now never oh no
no no no no
sometimes i would need oven mitts if i
could afford my ass
one plot what you've got you've got to
pull a dump and jump get right in the
shower
one ply not even roll up the window
that's crazy one ply yeah go through
that pick in my nose
there was a time in the not so
distant past
when
you know funds were quite tight you were
one you were peeling the ply no i wasn't
peeling the ply but you would go hold on
there's no excuse a single man in living
in new york city man or woman living in
new york city
you can steal toilet paper where you
don't got to be peeling the plot i'm not
saying i'm not peeling the plies but i'm
saying
so a lot of times especially in new york
that way bigger ass
every two three shits
i'll get you on the next one i'll be
back
um
no i would tell you hopping right into
the shower i don't like that i did that
once i don't like it
because i'm pooping in the shower i
don't i can't do it there you are yeah
sometimes just gonna use your foot and
get it down the drain real quick
sometimes i've
had i've been in the shower or like and
just got out or be in the shower and
like oh i have to [ __ ] oh that's the
[ __ ] worst do you mean hell feels
like you're on a water slide oh my god
guys you're on shotgun falls that's just
slipping all over the place yeah that's
it for me man the moment
or the [ __ ]
toilet paper's all wet oh get the [ __ ]
out of here that is my worst nightmare
uh-huh so i always try to dance around a
little bit in the morning [ __ ] make
sure she
shakes out shake out before i hop in the
shower with some wd-40 to get the rust
off
back in like a bottle of ketchup
um yeah that's tough so what'd you do
you didn't sell oh i would go to the
bodega and get to want like that's they
because they
you can buy the one roll out of bodega
but then in new york you can buy one
anything i'll say you want light bulb oh
yeah they'll open up they don't like the
whole like hey don't open up not forget
that's my toy we prefer those that's
scott
that stuff stinks no it doesn't you're
crazy it's one ply
oh i like it oh no it's stink that's got
teeth on it for me it gets a little grip
you start with that quilted shirt i
don't give you roids
that stuff that stuff gets you bad
steroids
you have roid rage i think it'll be
throbbing down there oh that's the last
thing i need is roids
roid's in the gout
keep those two away from me
i don't like it yeah um all right this
one's from my boy alex cinello have you
ever been to a bar on bar rescue
[Laughter]
before or after
either it's a tough look because i tell
you what the big guy really cleans the
place up nice yeah shout out to taff oh
i used to love that show i love it and
it's like wildly scripted the whole
stakeout like
i used to love he's saying that big
giant not me it's all real to me baby i
love taft love big big fan he makes you
want to eat and drink the way he talks
that's him
[Laughter]
but the way he figures
hey buddy stop rocking back and forth
all right i'm right here tone it down
we're all in the same room let's keep it
to an eight-ball episode
[ __ ] screaming at me
it's only appetizers
hey buddy we're at a shot and beard kind
of place all right
jukeboxes play and relax
man some of those bars i'm trying to
unwind some of those bars and like
that's that's places like like imagine
if that was the town bar that's where
you had to go dude
if you go to a restaurant they're
cooking something on a toaster oven
[Laughter]
in a hallway
dude
get out of there
he would always try to like
it would be like a shot and beer biker
boar place and he's like i'm thinking
family fun and it's like dude i got two
words pretzel buns yeah it's like dude
they're moving meth out of the back of
here they don't care about the ambiance
cash is falling out of the drop ceiling
it's like dude chris what are you doing
oh man i tell that show the love they
bring in some like mixologists from like
fridays and yeah it's always like johnny
cocktails or something
[Laughter]
that like does the flare up in it nice
that [ __ ] lasts two seconds let me get
three kentucky manhattan your whiskey
gingers you're like what the [ __ ]
i knew a guy who was opening up a comedy
club and he goes everything i need to
know about running a business i saw on
bar rescue and then we found out he was
half a million dollars in debt one year
later yeah
and so
put the poppers in that place sir
the lines were clean
the lines were clean look at that
yeah screaming at somebody yeah
so funny that was a great show great
show shout out to the dad shout out to
him he's up there with dog for me
oh man when dog dropped when i was in
college
that was that's when [ __ ] that's when a
e was like [ __ ] it oh yeah [ __ ] it let's
go yeah and run around with that bear
spray
stuff that mace or whatever
like dude if you ran up on me we'd shoot
a fair one real [ __ ] quick dog
i would [ __ ] yeah i'd shoot the fade
with you
[ __ ] see me out
reality show royal rumble bar rescue
versus pawn stars versus dog the bounty
hunter you can pick whoever else who's
coming out on top dog what are you
[ __ ] nuts
dog all day she's got one of his bozo
sons with yeah those those i'd [ __ ]
grab him by the ponytail those kids are
looking to kill somebody
i'm surprised they haven't i'm surprised
they haven't got jammed up already yeah
they're all wearing tactical gear and
stuff like that
it's your day off what are you doing
wearing a bulletproof vest to go see his
mom and [ __ ]
it's in the grocery store he's got his
pants tucked into his boots
[Laughter]
you got to get off the icebreak
[Laughter]
ah i love the dog
good-looking man too awesome
uh that you know this isn't a topic show
but you see when he went down there to
try to fight he was like i'll find brian
laundry in like two days he went down
there and then like in miami or wherever
he hit his sizzlers dude there was he
was at the brunch every day at like the
hot spots there was like him doing him
doing like [ __ ] bloody marys and
stuff all he did was go to the parents
house and bang on their front door
where's he at
all right i'm back to hawaii
[Laughter]
yeah that guy's all talk
oh god if you hear from him i'm sleeping
in the car right
i'll be in the tahoe
i always have to always they have a nice
fleet of rides though i gotta give them
that they always kept a nice big black
escalade
his wife died right
like he screamed
i'm all hopped up on tapper
his wife died right
he's right there jesus christ tone it
down
i've never heard you see you act like
general
twice died right
i guess this guy
that covets got you man man
i'm all backwards dude i don't know
what's happening
i got microchipped or something
a [ __ ] screwball we got a bad
processor
i'm running on android
[Laughter]
hippie needs an update
you got a kickstander what's going on
yeah i got a lot i got locked out of my
operating system can't remember i don't
know where i put the exclamation point
give me got a nokia booster
man
another home run of a question i don't
even know how that started and to answer
no never been to a
bar rescue bar
um there was a comedy club that did it
in like arizona or something
yeah never been there have you have you
been there though have you ever eaten
something that guy fieri has eaten i've
eaten a guy fieri's restaurant
out of the trash but
this is still warm out of the trash at
his house
um huge guy fieri fan
love him love him to death huge diner
drivers and dives obviously
let's do the joke for the listener on
the road when we're driving somewhere
don't come to a new restaurant
i always go hey
[Music]
oklahoma
my co-host is a fat tubby [ __ ] where
he's gonna eat his body weight in
cheeseburgers
you believe that [ __ ] dude
i was doing that we were laughing so
hard in the in like indiana or something
that we all we almost died i was
laughing until i blacked out and i was
just trying to hold the wheel straight
he opened up a joint here in new york uh
right around the corner it's this is
still there it's near near where the
action is i don't know it's near
broadway time square all that stuff i
don't know if it's still there it was
called like america fieri's american
something american grill or something
like that yeah all american grillers ate
there one night i tell you what kid
knows his way around a [ __ ] burger
yeah of course um service was excellent
i don't know if i've ever eaten anything
i'm sure probably something in philly
he's done i've eaten you know like one
of the sandwich like sandwich places or
[ __ ] lorenzo's pizza or whatever we
ate at a ramsey that's a that is a great
question i love ramsay that's a great
question though have you ever celebrity
any celebrity chef places is that that's
a good one
yeah uh ramsay's like on the fence for
me because he's a classically trained
chef let's be honest here he knows his
way around a [ __ ] egg beat we were in
the [ __ ] lounge of a
tropicana we they were playing keno two
feet away from us and people were saying
inside i think it was caesars was it i
don't know that was a nice restaurant
though it was a nice restaurant i mean
it was right
yeah it has the biggest chairs i've ever
seen for those fat nice [ __ ] tubs of
[ __ ] in atlantic city atlantic city
check it out on the smash
atlantic city
um
oh god
gordon ramsay eight guy fieri
but then there's like the wolfgang puck
that's not celebrity that's a nice giant
i would argue ramsay's probably top shot
i have a i have a wolfgang puck pressure
cooker in my in my apartment that i'm
too scared to throw out
why
am i here a terrorist yeah my aunt
wanted a casino when like well i took
one look at it got it home like we're
not using this oh you still got that
thing floating around i remember when
that was yeah
her
boat flooded or something right
yeah something right there was some sort
of she had sort of she had a boat parked
outside of the bargata to flood it
i don't that wasn't that though that was
just she's a parking garage she used to
gamble she used to go down there a lot
they'd get on her on the weekends and um
you know she's a high roller so you know
they give you stuff they were like uh
must have been real high rollers hey hey
take this this was the lower i got this
stuff did she have nice she's a nice
comforter and like all that it's all
that kind of stuff high-end stuff
whatever they give away to gamblers i
don't know i mean he's a comforter and
rice cooker so far i mean
pressure cooker there's a difference you
can do multiple things in it yeah but
anyway terrorism i'm sure yeah i'm too
scared to use it i'm not putting out
much i'm not doing that to my super end
up on a list
he's gonna have to report you
she got it at the goddamn casino i'm
sorry
um oh god
ma'am all right
let's get back on track here with a
couple of them
uh this is from kemper when was the last
time you had to dig through your own
trash at the curb
because you lost something yeah
i had my mom not too long a couple of
years
coffee grounds oh man this better be
something boring it's always that in a
banana peel oh nothing skis me out like
that
coffee grounds in there
there's coffee grounds in every trash
can in america right now for some reason
even if you don't drink coffee there's
coffee grounds in there
my mom threw my keys out one time what
the [ __ ] not too long ago karen hill
that's all we had karen why what were
you guys we were fighting no they were
like on a newspaper it was like on like
a [ __ ] something and like you know
you're drinking and a friend trying to
keep you're not gonna drive kippy
don't go down there like that kippy come
on cool off it was one of those things
where i searched the whole house i'm
like they were here [ __ ] an hour ago
no one's left what's happening i don't
you love that where you know somebody
touched it no no oh yeah it's over there
[ __ ] it yeah
i i'm pretty i'm still on the record my
stepdad stole 100 bill that i had one
time it was on the kitchen counter and
he took it um all right let's get into
another one here
we've recently touched on this a little
bit but this is from johnny trash ever
worked with a parent at a business that
your family doesn't own
is a tough one say that one more time
have you ever worked with a parent at a
business that your family doesn't own
like if you and your mom are co-workers
that's a tough look you do what you got
to do
but yeah that's a tough look yeah it's
bad
unless you know you're in like high
school and like you work at like where
your dad works like on the loading dock
or something that's a little different
yeah
yeah wow anytime families are involved
because it's typically like it's a
dirtbag thing and i've worked in those
companies where it's like they're hiring
anyone they're taking it all you need is
like a collared shirt in the interview
and they just like pi i worked at this
law firm it was like a pump and dump
scheme and it was dirt bags from all
over philly and like
at one point sitting there and i'm like
how does everybody know each other like
oh that's my cousin that's my aunt
that's her sister that's her
mother-in-law i'm like
well there's a 70 year old and a 12 year
old working together
you're working with a wolfel street road
yeah street road dude oh man driving
into work with your parents that's
picking up your mom for work
bumping toward happy hour that's bad
someone else recently talked about did
you ever like drop your parents off at
work so you could have the car oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah what are you nuts it's tough
summer times [ __ ] in the 90s i'll get up
and drop patty off at the [ __ ] at the
office be back around four to get you
honey
no problem that means
blazer or something would you have uh
she we rocked
through the 90s pretty solid uh patty
rolled and exclusively tight blondes
then
[Laughter]
cypress hill um nissan maxima
always had the freshest one every three
ever you know she leased them so every
three years
the weekends those things that was like
a race car when i was a kid those things
were cool looking back in the 90s a
little bit i always had
very russian mafia vibes to me hey
keep everybody
always rock them she had a white one
that was sick right before they changed
them over it was tight
looked like a lexus that's what i told
people anyway
it's really you know it's the same boss
same chassis that's always a real
dirtbag oh yeah
you know nissan owns lexus you know it's
the same line same tire yeah whatever
kick rocks in your mom's car
i was whipping a 96 chevy lumina big
body
that thing was sweet painful paint
falling off and all
um
all right let's see here let's do a
couple more and we gotta wrap her up
this one's from brent wall first time
long time never had a question read do
any of your condiments come in glass
bottles or jars because that's classy
that's very classic i don't think no
maybe
one special salad dressing that she got
on sale or something like that salad
dressing tends to
be
glass i feel maybe not ours i don't know
there's i feel like there's always one
like thai chili sauce that's been in the
fridge for like 19. there's some sort of
special jam or something yeah a jelly
you know what i started to notice with
with the kinds of salad dressings that
my mom was buying for a while this is
recently that get me to creamy reach
that was big in my house oh honey
mustard it was
dude last summer that salad dressing
i think we're getting to the crux of the
weight issue
that's what i was gonna say you guys had
any ketchup for my salad
all the salad dressings
in my mom's house whatever brand she has
they all say salad dressing and marinade
oh yeah
no that's a one-stop shop for dirt balls
yeah salad dressing
salad dressing marinade and conditioner
i'm telling you the real the honey
mustard blow your hair back but she
would she because she she would soak she
would soak chicken in in honey mustard
and we'd do it on the grill comes out
awesome yeah [ __ ] a grill up though
i've been there
yeah the grill's dirty yeah yeah you
gotta wear a welder's mask when you're
dropping them
that'll [ __ ] i'll take the eyebrows
off
um
sleeping
dude that [ __ ] leaves skin on the grill
like a motorcycle accident
that's such an uncle uncle movie ah
little flare-up yeah get back get back
in here
what'd i tell you yeah give me a plate
yeah i don't know what it is about a guy
with a grill but he's never got enough
clean plates
i've had to pull that trigger tell him
how to get a plate quick
for some reason you think he can't i
gotta play i can get a plate
no tongs or nothing dude flip it with
your hands i've done that [ __ ]
you gotta you gotta fork you're trying
to
try to get to the back fall that heats
up real quick on the knuckles oh yeah
ouch i thought this happened to me the
other night and i thought i wanted to
ask you guys how do you get a frozen
pizza out of the oven
i have a i've recently i get into the
oven
cook it in the shower with me
uh i have a
i like to eat it i like to dine in
[Laughter]
uh i use like a i have like a big knife
that i'll like from the back and slide
it out well here's the thing uh at my
house nothing can go into the oven if
something like that if i'm like trying
to heat up a piece of ilios she always
demands that it goes on tinfoil so it
doesn't the crumbs don't get in the
bottom of the pan get out of here and
that tin foil is like space age that
[ __ ] cools off in like point two seconds
i don't understand you can grab that
right out of the oven yeah but sometimes
you get stuck on a bottle you're eating
you're eating something you're chewing
some metal at the end of the day
you have to negotiate yeah you do have
to negotiate with the corners why don't
you get an elio's surprise even a little
pam is what you should do oh
look at you
but but if you use temple you're getting
a soggy bottom pizza
it's not no that's not true it's not as
christmas if it's right on a grate
everybody says right on the grate you
know what you should do if you weren't a
[ __ ] bozo
you put stop eating pizza yeah stop
eating healings at 45.
when you're 400 pounds
marinating in honey mustard yeah um you
take uh
the tin foil goes on the bottom of the
bottom of the oven i know that always
sits there though that's a toaster of
that because that's because you come
from a toaster oven family we never did
that though oh really oh my friend's
parents houses that had toaster ovens
you wouldn't know
it was like you needed [ __ ] an
archaeologist to [ __ ] figure out the
layers it's like yo lady clean this out
before i put my [ __ ] bagel bite
biting there were you jesus christ
sometimes we'll be at the 7-eleven in
[ __ ] the airport
it's ridiculous
like you didn't know where you were
going to go with that the airport wasn't
your first choice
but it was the right choice yeah it was
very funny very um
hang on a second okay were you a pam
family growing up because we weren't
that [ __ ] didn't come into our house
until a couple years ago yeah i would
say maybe that was rich people [ __ ]
maybe high school there was be a can
floating around i wasn't allowed to
touch it it was like that no one
no one that was like i never i never
touched that and then once i figured out
what it was i was like banksy
[Laughter]
oh man every pan was getting it [ __ ]
dude you cooking i was putting i was
putting on top of toast
out of the shower dab will do you when
it comes to pam i used to overuse the
[ __ ] out of that when we started having
it just to watch the eggs slide around
oh man so you need to have to clean it
just put it right back in the [ __ ]
cabinet i know that's great um i love
having a nice egg a nice little little
pan making a single uh over easy egg
little flips yeah
simplicity you know what i had down the
shore which i don't know where they came
i think it was down the shore they had
the circle john's with the little handle
that makes the perfect circle fried egg
yeah you're a mcdonald's yeah yeah you
just you spray the inside of that with
pam
[ __ ] crack the egg cooks it right in
there take it out flip it over right on
a baggie yeah they started to
i think mcdonald's is starting to become
a little more honest about that that
they use them
uh and they're becoming a little more
mainstream people are using them what
those little circle things that's what
mcdonald's does what do you mean the
little circle things that's what you're
talking about right the little circle
that what the perfect egg cooks in the
middle of it yeah it's like a little
it's like a cookie cutter yeah yeah yeah
that's a mcdonald's use
they're starting to become popular now
with home use yeah yeah yeah and i feel
like mcdonald's is pushing out more that
like as i've seen mcdonald's commercials
where they show them with them cracking
the egg in there yeah yeah well that was
never real egg before they're trying to
get on the real egg
they're definitely real legs now yeah
yeah i don't know i haven't had in a
long time either
um
you know what i don't know we gotta get
out of here i believe right t-bone yeah
um
well we used to use it just when we were
talking about marinating the chicken um
was really trashy uh we might have
talked about this italian dressing yeah
oh yeah are you kidding me they would do
my well we had there was five things you
were having for dinner montreal
[Laughter]
throw it into neutral baby
montreal chicken was the first meal i
had where i was like what the [ __ ] is
this dude i blew my [ __ ] my mom would
be like james gonna make the montreal
chicken before we used that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] everything when we discovered it
talking about the perfect combination of
spices i felt like an international
traveler montreal that's in canada but i
give my dad credit my dad's watching
this right now he brought montreal steak
seasoning into our house for the first
time we use that every [ __ ] meal for
like two years straight
steaks chops mix some and mix some in
the burger it's really good yeah oh that
stuff was tight you know what we had
this is
really trash with the as seen on tv ron
popeil thing
was it
yeah
it
it was like a casserole dish clear
plastic whatever you know like
tupperware type thing had a lid with
like a valve on it and you would put the
chicken in there with the uh italian
dressing and then like a hose at the top
and it would vacuum it would pull all
the air out
and pull suck the air out so like it was
created like a vacuum so
the idea was the
italian dressing got like infused in the
chicken
it never worked
it was dude that's the trash it sounded
like an air compressor it's not like you
were blowing up your tires was it only
for chicken and italian dressing no but
i mean that's all we did
yeah and inflating air mattresses yeah
yeah
it was a tough luck it was bad man it
was one of those things where like they
were like oh check this out you're like
this ain't gone away i do i'll be honest
with you we thought that was good but me
i remember me and my brother like you
know we started to like you know like to
eat like you know we got in like middle
school and high school and stuff like
that i'm not saying it was bad i'm
saying it was good i'm saying the
product it was like hey check this out
like there's no way this thing's gonna
[ __ ] work yeah who'd you use
we talked about this lightly about the
italian dressing that has the glass
bottle newman's the white top no not
newman's that was awesome you mix it
yourself no mix don't [ __ ]
make it over yourself don't talk to me
about ken's yeah the packet okay can't
think of who it is we used to have it in
its own in a how in a bottle you would
make it i guess okay oh yeah i'm sorry
i'm trying to get there with you
try salad dressing it would be in like a
vase type thing with like a white lid
with it clicks on
oh my god i wouldn't it wasn't 4c but it
was some with somebody i know we've
mentioned it on the podcast real trash
[ __ ] ah good seasonings i think i'm not
i mean that was that i barely wrote i
was like six when that was happening
yeah [ __ ] was all right that a little
crystal light back when the living was
easy baby on a nice summer night
folks that's where we're going to leave
you this week
out on the porch any time
fireworks show starts in an hour
just a little slice of americana
um dang we [ __ ] love you yeah check
out the special share with a friend we
posted a [ __ ] everywhere thank you so
much the support has been so [ __ ]
awesome so far i mean everybody dms and
unless that's so good can't thank you
enough yeah really keep sharing it new
tour coming 2022. going everywhere
everywhere we're gonna be in [ __ ]
denver salt lake
phoenix tampa detroit tampa orlando
detroit baby buffalo
pittsburgh everywhere going back to
chicago chicago
t-bone great job on the special buddy
great job pal you guys too you guys
[ __ ] killed it man i [ __ ] love you
all right
peace